foreign
New York hi Nate welcome to the Ramsay
show
hi Dave how you doing better than I
deserve what's up
yeah so I guess my main question is like
I have a
the main question I guess is how should
I go about paying off my debt what kind
of debt do you have
so
um
yeah so I have uh about 48 Grand and
private student loans
and um
19 Grand in federal student loans
I have a
uh about 12 Grand on my car
and I have a seven and a half Grand
personal loan
what's your income
yeah so my take-home pay right now is
about 2600 a month okay uh how old are
you
I'm 23. what do you do
I'm a support technician for my
company's r d what'd you get your degree
in
math
okay yeah okay yes I so I had this
opportunity so uh I was admitted into uh
Masters in applied math program all the
way across the country
um and uh
but right now I have about like three
grand in my savings
and um
I also have about 2500 in a 401k I don't
know why I
put money in there
at this point right uh so uh I I do
you're a math guy and you understood
compound interest you wanted to get
involved
that's it yeah but uh the the equation
here the equation here is simple you've
got a big hole of of debt and your
income needs to come up so we need to be
working on ways to get that income up
short term and long term right you're
just getting started 23 years old you're
just getting started
um I'm sure there's plenty of ways to
move up in the field that you're in
right
over time I think so yeah I think so I
my my my biggest so my the plan I kind
of have right now is I'm thinking about
just trying to get a second job right
like working as much as I can yep and
then like but I don't know if so next
year by next September like let's say I
have like you know 20 so right now I'm
staying with my grandmother and like uh
I'm I'm trying to not spend any money on
anything that's good um
again let me go back the equation is
simple what we're doing here is we're
getting our income up in the short term
that's looking like working an extra
part-time job some side hustles and
trying to get this paid off as quickly
as possible another thing you can do is
make sure that you're writing down your
expenses and what you're spending
through your budget because that's
you're going to optimize your money in
that way so those are the two things
that you need to be doing lowering your
expenses through budgeting and
increasing your income through part-time
side jobs that sort of thing and that's
that is the only way to skin the cat on
this one you know there's no magic thing
Nate I took every math class that was
available to me all the way through AP
um math is my thing I love it so I love
the way your brain works it's my the way
mine works and here's my warning don't
over Analyze This
okay I nowadays when I'm talking to
someone like you I use big math I call
it meaning very little analysis so what
I'm looking at is I just added it up
real quick in my head you got 86 000 in
debt and you make thirty five thousand
dollars a year okay
eighty six thousand dollars in debt
means you need to power forty three
thousand a year for two years and you're
debt free so what have we got to do to
do that you need to make about thirty
five thousand dollars more than you're
making right now and so you're going to
lean in on your current job push push
push do anything you can do to get
promotions and move up or change your
current job to a better one and you're
going to work like a maniac at the best
possible paying side hustle I don't care
if it's cleaning septic tanks or walking
dogs do whatever you got to do for two
years and get your butt in gear and go
find you forty three thousand dollars a
year for two years and you're done man
you're 25 years old and you're debt free
the whole mess is cleaned up and you
will have learned some things about Nate
that you don't know right now
you will like him even better because I
like him I think he's a good guy
do you think it's like worth it to take
uh the school opportunity so you're
broke no you don't need a master's in
Applied Mathematics you need a job
right
you got to go get some money you have a
mess
yeah so Jade comes out 38 000 in income
with a couple of Music degrees did I get
that right you're about right and 465
000 in debt they did not get out of 465
000 in debt her and Sam in seven years
with thirty eight thousand dollars you
know what they did they got their butt
in gear you got to work man and they got
their incomes up and their income up
some more and their income up some more
and they were making serious money by
the end of the story but the beginning
of the story was pitiful in the
beginning of your story is pitiful but
the end of your story is going to be
amazing because you have that ability
my only like concern so there's like
don't analyze this Nate quit you got
you're getting paralysis of the analysis
already
you got to get in gear man you gotta
Roar it's a it's a simple simple
equation be a little Dumber for the
purposes of getting this done this is
just be a Workhorse you know just get
your butt in how much money can I make
legally and morally how much can I work
and don't worry you're not going to die
from overwork right before you die you
pass out don't worry about it hey
there's this
um I'm sure you've read Atomic Habits by
James clear and he talks about the idea
of Motion versus action and the motion
is I'm reading all the books I'm doing
all the math equations I'm rolling it
over in my head over and over but the
time comes when you actually have to act
and do the things that you're reading
about thinking about listening to
podcasts about asking Dave's advice
about at some point the motion has to
transfer to action and that's the only
way that you're gonna get out of this
thing but I mean you and Sam just throw
your shoulders back and roared yeah you
just went ah I'm going you know that's
what you did you have to you guys went
and you worked and and you did some
crazy stuff oh yeah that was legal yeah
but it was like you look back on it
you're like you you're nuts and that's
what that's what Nate's got to do you
gotta you don't have kids you're not
married you can do crazy stuff like get
a bunch of Roommates so you're paying
pinch you know stay with Grandma for
free that's crazy right there you can do
things like you know sell everything
you've got you can get rid of this car
if you need to and get a two thousand
dollar card there's there's a lot that
you can do you can work to all hours of
the night you're 23 years old your body
doesn't you know don't get me wrong you
need sleep but I'm saying you can do you
can do the crazy right now and do it now
dude don't put this off until you know
10 years on Down the Line listen money
comes from action and work go get you
some that's right forty three thousand
dollars a year for two years you're done
and then call me up we'll have you come
down here you can stand on this debt
free scream we'll give you a big old hug
and tell you we're proud of you because
that's where you're going man that's who
you are you're you're not a wilted
Little Snowflake